the actor who plays your adult son on
the left over silca right yes it that
you find him attractive sure and that
you sometimes when you're on camera you
have a hard time not touching him which
of course creates a creepy subliminal
vibe you're watching the show that mama
is like hey for anybody that watched the
show last season we had very little
material together and then there was
this flashback episode where you see
this family when it was intact and Chris
and I just adore each other and I was
doing a scene and he was like you know
my college-age son and I was like I'm so
happy you're home I'm so happy you're
home I'm so happy you're home and the
director said it's not quite you know
but Zylka has what my friend takes yeah
what is it what is it that makes him so
attractive I'm gonna break down for you
Conan I'm gonna break down he has what
my friend Taye Diggs house which is this
wild combination of muscularity so like
nice like male muscularity and super
soft skin like it's like who has that
and when you're around it you cannot
stop touching it you know I don't have
like nattie of the science more like a
ripe peach or something you know it's
just very you're just drawn to it
I have like areas of soft skin you know
there's no musculature so that's nice so
but that would create a problem is that
what awaits me oh man I mean look at
Game of Thrones didn't that hole and
start the whole ball of wax like that
weird ancestor you're right
incest is cool
that's a good quote yeah Coenen says
incest school that's gonna be just the
tabloids we'll just take that out just
those quotes at celebrities yeah I like
onions
he says his tools yeah as your husband
okay was it is he okay with the fact
that you're working with attractive men
we've been together so long well he met
me rubbing up David Caruso way back I
mean he's like I've been rubbing up in
strange man you know most of our
marriage that was that was part of your
job let's be clear that was I've rubbed
up against David Caruso Justine
elevators Elka when the cameras aren't
rolling you know the only celebrity who
I've been mistaken for I like I don't
know why I don't even think we I think
it's just the red hair but I remember
people always know cuz I don't look like
anybody else right with that but one
person was like I do I love you on CSI
you know is that what it's called what
you want to see oh yes yeah I don't know
say thank you
what did you say thank you I did and
then I made out for an hour
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please